Sophie. Yes Finn? Our topic for the day: Describe your daily routine... Ok, great.
using lots and lots of adverbs... lots of adverbs, got it...great.  So I usually wake up
around 7 am. Me too:  breakfast?
Yeah, I'll try and have breakfast.
sometimes I get up too late so I'll just grab a banana and run out
of the door (very good) and then if it is raining, I always
get the bus (yeah)
but if the weather is alright, I'll walk - takes about 20 minutes.
How about you?
I always take the tube. Always?
It's so far. If I was to take the bus it would take too long.
What time do you go for lunch? About one o'clock usually. I think I  pretty much always have
lunch at one.
That's very precise.
one until two, every day, exactly. That's good though, it breaks up the day a bit,
doesn't it? It does. What about - when do
you finish work? About six o'clock most days,
some days if I can escape a little bit earlier that happens occasionally - don't tell the boss -
No, absolutely - Never tell the boss - How about you?
I usually finish at six actually.
And then what do you do with your evenings?
WIth my life? I go home and I rarely cook actually
Noooo... I always cook. I love to cook dinner.
Maybe once a week - rarely cook - sometimes eat
in a restaurant, sometimes eat with friends
That's nice - Yeah, and then usually go to bed at about midnight.
About midnight? Oh no, I'm in bed by ten o'clock. Really?
Yeah, otherwise I'm really grumpy in the
morning.
Incredible - Well done you!
Thanks!